in a historic move the city council in
asheville north carolina voted
unanimously
to approve a reparations resolution for
black residents
the resolution calls for the city to
make investment in areas where black
residents face disparities
it also asked the city manager to create
a plan to build
generational wealth and boost economic
mobility in
the black community the resolution also
includes a formal apology for the role
the city played in slavery
and enforcing racist policies and gail
we should note the resolution stopped
short of stipulating direct payments but
we're seeing momentum
for measures like this in places like
providence rhode island and california
and gail the fact that this is happening
in a former confederate state was noted
by keith young
one of the two african ameri american
member council members he said
hundreds of years of black blood spilled
that basically fills the cup we drink
from today
man i say go asheville north carolina
you know a lot of people are opening
themselves up to this conversation for
the very first time
i think it's important when you look at
the history you you'll have a better
understanding
about why so many people are pushing for
that so i think this is a good thing